welcome to this course about development
with large language models or llms
throughout this course you will complete
Hands-On projects that will help you
learn how to harness the immense
potential of LMS for your own projects
you'll build projects with LNS that will
enable you to create Dynamic interfaces
interact with vast amounts of Text data
and even Empower LMS with the capability
to browse the internet for research
papers you'll learn about the intricate
workings of LMS from their historical
Origins to the algorithms that power
models like GPT option is a passionate
educator in the field and he teaches
this course
hi welcome to this course on llm
engineering and development brought to
you by loop.ai my name is akshat and I'm
excited to be teaching you guys this
course
so who should watch this anyone who's
interested to learn Hands-On llam usage
in theory through explanations and
multiple guide projects paired with a
fairly basic Python Programming
knowledge should be pretty comfortable
following along
so here are all the projects that we're
going to be working towards we're going
to be able to create a clone of the chat
gbd user interface along with the large
language model that will help us
interact with it with custom personas
we're going to be able to have
conversation so with our documents like
text files and PDF files uh that chair
gbd may have not been trained on we're
going to be able to use Asians which are
self-prompting large language models and
enable these large language models to
browse the web and research and literary
research papers using the archive API
we're going to be able to enable these
large language models to use more than
five tools in the real world along with
equipping them with their own custom
tools
so here's all the course content and
let's get started with the basic
introduction to other guns
so an llm basically happens when you
combine a massive neural network with
huge amounts of data and train it on
this huge amounts of data once it's been
trained you then align it to human
values in an attempt to create a
reasoning engine so examples of these
LMS are bird llama more famously gbt 3.5
and gpt4
so the concept of alums has been around
since 1996 but why have they only
recently gained traction
the reason why is because this is the
first time in history where llms have
been actually able to outperform human
reasoning in certain contexts and the
reason for this is due to a huge import
improvements in performance and scale
now more on scale uh as you can see
modern llms like gbd 3.5 have a huge
amount of money and skill that goes into
developing them GP 3.5 has over 175
billion parameters and you can think of
parameters as neurons in your brain
along with this it has huge amounts of
training data
GPT 3.5 is not where this cycle of LM
development stops because open air has
another model called gpt4 that is
essentially an upgraded version of GPT
2.5 that performs all the data GPT 3.5
can but just seems to meet the goal a
lot better
the reason for this is due to its huge
amount of parameters 1.76 trillion and
with this it has the capacity to undergo
training with even greater amounts of
training data
a huge model like this that's trained on
a huge amount of training data is pretty
dangerous to humanity so the demand for
aligning this model to human values and
feedback is also very important and
plays a very important role
apart from GB 3.5 and gpd4 by openai
there are several competitors in this
landscape like Microsoft Facebook Google
who are all actively publishing
resubscribers and breakthroughs pretty
much every week at the time when this is
recorded
so now let's look through some of the
algorithmic breakthroughs that got us to
this point I'm going to go through these
by explaining to you the typical
architecture that you would follow uh if
you want to train your own custom large
language model so let's start with
choosing the architecture and tokens
so
a large language model you can think of
is basically a mathematical function
that has just learned to predict the
right words given the given some input
context
and if you want to use this as a
mathematical function you'd obviously
have to deal in numbers so we use
something called tokenization that
converts a string of text into a vector
of numbers
and so the tokenizer splits these words
into individual elements and then
assigns it a unique number
so once you assign the unique number uh
you also need to tell the llm when to
actually stop generating or otherwise
it'll be stuck in an input too and
that's why you have this stop token here
so now let's look at the brain which is
actually what learns these relationships
between words and predicts the right
word
so you don't need to really know all the
complex math that goes in that gets
involved in
making this neural network for this
course but I'm just going to give you a
quick intuition as to how this works so
let's say one of this input sequence
like this word here gets inputted you
can think of all these layers as random
numbers initially and what you can think
of them doing is just multiplying them
multiplying this input sequence uh yeah
these many times and then you would get
an output
so obviously if all these layers are set
to random numbers you're gonna have a
pretty bad and random guess so what we
do after we call that the output is we
look at what word we actually want the
model to output and then we compute a
difference between our output value that
we predicted and the the actual value
that we need once we have that the
algorithm takes node and it adjusts all
of these parameters here uh to step in
that direction
so once that's done
we've pretty much finished one training
step and and adding to this overall
scale concept this whole training
process occurs hundreds of billions of
times so you can imagine that even after
the first 10 million iterations it's
going to get pretty good at guessing
what the next word is supposed to be
so now more on the training problem I
was just talking about
the way these large language models are
trained is through a next word token
prediction task which basically gives
the model the question as well as a
blank that it's supposed to fill in so
here obviously the answer is books so
it's given all this context here
surrounding context and it's asked to
predict the word
so these these are just four questions
here but the model gets inputted
billions of questions from data uh from
code to college textbooks to articles to
lyrics to podcasts and pretty much any
data that you can scrape off the
internet
so good so now we've effectively trained
this model that can predict the next
token in our sequence but this is still
very limiting because it's just one
token we want we want our slm to ideally
express ideas and thoughts and actually
reason so the way we do that is by
actually predicting this next token here
and then inputting the predicted token
back into the model so that it can
predict again and you just keep you know
collecting these predictions and you'll
get a string of text and
um going back to the stop token this is
where it's important because once the
model is finished with the thought it
needs to be informed that
um yeah you should just stop the thought
so great so now we have this huge llm
that's been trained on a bunch of
different data and we can use it as a
reasoning engine but maybe the llm
doesn't have the knowledge that it needs
in order to work in your specific use
case and this is where fine tuning comes
in fine tuning
um find you can use fine tuning to
further train a model to your own
personal context and this is good
because you don't need that much data
anymore you just need a small label
Corpus of your example data and examples
of something that you can use fine
tuning for is generating custom mid
Journey or image generation prompts for
another model as well as letting it
learn information Beyond its knowledge
cut off so you know say
um you wanted to teach it about the
latest cancer research
so a quick note here uh the second
example where you're actually teaching
it information it's not the most
efficient uh when you find you we're
going to be using a much better method
called Vector databases in this course
uh more on that later but generally
you'd fine tune if you want to change
its Behavior like this example here
so now that we have this model with its
optional fine tuning you can further
take this to production and make it safe
so that it doesn't
um spear harmful content through RL HF
which is reinforcement learning from
Human feedback the reason we do this is
because the the training data that we
scrape comes from a bunch of different
sources like articles podcasts textbooks
lyrics Etc and this data is bound to
have a lot of bias in it and alignment
with human values basically fine tunes
it to remove the bias so here's
um here's what they do what open AI does
to fix this issue
so basically it's uh it uses a human
labeler to just get safe output and
reinforce the model to Output these safe
tokens
okay so now we pretty much went through
the entire pipeline which is everything
from training to fine tuning to aligning
to human values and now we're gonna
actually look into how to get the output
from our models so the the question that
you asked the process of asking a large
language model a question is called
prompting
and the model generates something called
a completion which is just a string of
text that's likely to complete your
previous text
inference parameters are another
technique that you can use to enhance
the creativeness of the model and we'll
be trying this out in the chat gbt
playground but these are the four
parameters you can change so these two
basically make your outputs more random
by changing a lot of things like the
window for the probable words to how
much these low probability words are
weighted
add frequency parity and presence parity
are the other two inference parameters
and they basically make sure that your
model doesn't output the same answer in
the same style for every single for
every single identical question that you
ask it so now let's go ahead and try
this out in the chat GPD player
so quick ignore from this future uh if
you already know the basics of chat GPT
and calling the API You Should Skip the
next two sections and come to the third
section where we'll be learning how to
clone the entire chat GPT user interface
so now let's explore the playground
environment
so in your browser just type in chat GPT
breakdown and you should be prompted
with this user interface here
another way you could do this is just
through the open AI website itself
where you just log in
and done
okay
and just hit API here
and just hit play dot Okay so
the reason why we're choosing to use the
playground over the usual charge gbt
user interface is because the playground
will give us a more
customizability as well as a better feel
for the actual API that we're going to
be using throughout this course so let's
get started from um left to right in
this column here you can add in your
system message uh like and say you are a
programmer
something like that and basically the
system message assigns the llm's
personality throughout the entire
conversation so here you can maybe say
something like our high
could end out the first 10 and date
sheet so
it pull it okay
defense
and it should give you some Outlet
okay
so as you can see it does give us the
output and one thing to notice here is
that there's always an alternation
between the user and the assistant and
so in the API as well when we script
some kind of conversation we're going to
be using this so just remember that it's
only valid it
it's user followed by assistant
so now let's move on to this main column
here that is going to let us customize a
bunch of different parameters so uh it's
generally recommended to keep the mode
in chat but
you can explore the models here and
we have options between the versions of
the GPD 3.5 line and the gpt4 line and
basically the difference between GT4 and
gdt 3.5 is uh gpt4 is slower but it's a
lot better at logical reasoning and
creativity related tasks because it's
just trained on so much data and gbt 3.5
is obviously the opposite is faster but
it's it's a little worse at uh you know
these tasks and so there's a speedo
there's a trade-off between intelligence
and speech here but in general I would
recommend using GPT code
so we can just give it another message
maybe I could write a poem
and yeah so as you can see uh the
previous
suffers so much faster than how it's
outputting now
and this process of like stringing
together these texts live is called
streaming where you're not uh you're not
just presenting uh the whole text after
it's all done processing you're just
doing it like it is putting it together
so now once we have this we can actually
change the other parameters here these
in press parameters so temperature is a
measure of
creativity as I've mentioned before so
when you put temperature at zero it's
very deterministic so it's useful when
you're trying to just try to understand
some kind of data and when temperature
equals one it's a lot more creative so
you can
you know use it for a bunch of different
uh
poem writing or just just like arguments
in general
maximum length is pretty obvious and so
just we can uh just test out the
deterministic part of this by comparing
to outputs so we can write direct code
for a lot
thing
sorting and
dirt from scratch
so I'll just copy this and uh
submit this
and while that's executing uh I'll just
go over like topi is another example
well that allows us to control the
modern's creativity and it's only advice
to you is one of these parameters uh at
a time uh either temperature or top B
so moving on we have frequency penalty
and presence polity and if you want the
model to Output a different answer for
every same question or just cut down the
number of repeated words in an answer
need to use this frequency parity so
anyway let's just so we did this when
temperature equals zero so now let's
compare this output to run temperature
equals uh something higher like well
so while that's happening uh as I said
before frequency penalty uh basically
penalizes based on how often a word
occurs by repeated verticals and
presence penalty penalizes the model
based on uh just whether or not the word
exists
so let's just compare these two outputs
with different temperatures so here the
algorithm is using bubble sort
but here the algorithm is using the home
selection sort so as you can see the
although the answers will be correct the
way it approaches these answers is going
to be widely different based on the
temperature or the top B
so another quick thing that we can do
here that makes our life a lot easier is
when we want to use this in the code
which we'll get to in the next session
you can just hit this view code button
it'll give us everything that we
actually need to get started so all we
have to do is just copy this code
and I'll see you in the next video where
we're actually gonna do
work through this API in our YouTube
channel
you should find this notebook Linked In
the description below and this is
something this is called a collab
notebook which is just an online
environment that helps us run our python
code so to get started all you have to
do is just press shift and enter and it
you can just go through all this collab
notebook
so we'll just wait for all the necessary
python packages to install and these
packages basically let us call the open
AI API and actually access charge apt so
let's just wait for that to finish
and let's go through
what this open ebi game means
middle black or not
okay
so now let's move on to this API key and
so what is an API key
since
open AI builds you on using the API
you'll need a password so that no one
can get access to this but you and
that's what the API key is it's just a
password to your API so obviously I'm
going to be revealing this password to
you guys but I'm going to deactivate it
as soon as this tutorial ends so I'm
going to show you guys how to do all of
that
so you don't have to worry even if
someone gets access to this key you can
just disable it so what you would do is
you would go out to your uh you know
this account and you would hit view API
keys and once you're in this dashboard
you can just create a new secret key you
can call it anything so for this one I'm
probably just gonna follow course Radio
2 for one and create the secret
I'm going to copy this now and
once it's copied I can just
yeah I can just paste it in here so this
will be a password that's unique to you
and say you've accidentally revealed
this what you can do is you can actually
just hit the trash icon here called
edible key and it basically disables the
gear so you can't access it through this
key anymore
I'm not gonna disable this but I've made
a couple of ones here that I'm going to
disable
and yeah I'm going to be disabling this
API key as soon as this video ends so
let's just
shift and enter and that runs this code
so your environment variable is now
opening Aid
and this is just an example of how we
call the epr
I'm not gonna use this as the example
I'm gonna go back here and go to the
playground and use this uh example that
open air has provided
so in this case let's just hit new chord
and then quality
yeah let's put there
okay so we can remove this open ABI Cube
if there's already defined that up here
and now
this response body in this content here
which is this part here we can just say
what is your name
and I'll show you guys the other games
after we're done with this
so as you can see it does run but it
doesn't just return us with the response
so what I can do is I can just uh the
whole value is
um in shorting this response variable so
I can just print out response
and as you can see it gives us a bunch
of the state up here and the only thing
we're actually interested in is this
part here right it says digital
assistant so notice how I decided it all
equals you through here but here it's
all equal to assistant the content is I
am in the AI language model developed by
open AI I don't have a personal name
whatever
so obviously this this
is the only thing that we want the model
the output and everything here is just
uh something that we shouldn't be you
know using so what we can do is we can
just
extract just to reply to this
and so this goes through the entire Json
data and it just gets us the content
here so it's the same thing here let's
run up here
so another thing you can do is again
just um everything that you do in this
playground you can do here so you can
put on system message here and the way
you do that is just by defining this
other dictionary
and
you put the row a system and the content
does whatever the system as it is so
here you can see your helpful assistant
um you know
obsess like potatoes
and shift enter again
it should take a little while but we
should be clicking on the output pretty
soon
yeah
so here
as you can see it does assign that
personality to it because you know it's
just potatoes but it also just completes
the task as well another thing that you
can notice in this example is I have the
power to change everything that I've
changed in this pretty loud so I have
the bar to change the model the messages
the temperature and if you come up here
you can actually see that everything
that I changed up there you can sort of
just assign a general variable and
change it I'm not going to be doing that
because I don't think it's very
necessary for this tutorial but we can
look to some more prompting now
so one thing to note is that GPD 3.5
doesn't really pay attention to the
system message as much so generally
whenever you want to assign a system
message you should be deported
so let's go to this example here which
is few short prompted
so if you guys remember what I said
about fine tuning in the previous in the
slides explanation this is sort of
analogous to that when you're sort of
giving the model example answers you're
scripting this entire conversation here
so you're saying that the system method
is this the user has inputted this and
the assistant has responded like this so
this didn't actually happen but you're
saying that this is like the ideal uh
response that the assistant should be
giving you and once you give it lineup
examples it sort of learns uh to you
know output the answer based on
how the user desires it so here let's
just change the model to gpd4
and we can run this code there
yeah so as you can see it does give us
this output we can try this
well we can track this is sort of a
simple example but we can try this maybe
Maybe
if so I'll just uh
what
liquid
so as you can see like we can compare
the output that it's given previously
with the few short prompting and now and
I would say like the output before was a
lot more concise and in-farm than
whatever this is
so again another example of things short
prompting where we can actually just
assign the system message as something
that follows pattern so that it it can
transistor
Mom it enhances whatever it learns so I
highly recommend you guys to just go
into this notebook it is just your API
Key by connecting with your car and just
simulating a bunch of conversations and
tweaking a lot of these parameters here
and so I'll get a feel for it because
there are no ideal set of parameters for
every
um for every problem
much like there is no ideal dump for
every problem it's a process that comes
from just uh you know keep or driving
error and just trying out a bunch of
different solutions
so one thing I didn't mention so far is
that like this API is actually built so
and the way open AI charges you for this
for using this API is through the number
of tokens so you can think of a token as
I've explained before as three-fourths
of a word approximately and so for every
three-fourths of a word every thousandth
reports of a word you would be charged
differently based on what model you're
using so this took this Library here
um sort of helps us understand how much
we're using it but we are a much better
way to do this is just going through uh
is going through your manage account and
just looking through uh how much you're
being built because openm provides you
with all the data and accessory we're
here is just a way to do this
programmatically
um you can just this is just something
where you just copy paste the code in
and it helps you with that there's
really no bonded understanding what this
means
okay so as you can see it's counted 129
prompt tokens so you can just do the lab
and see how much that charges so in
general the high-end models like gpd4
are slightly more expensive than gbt 3.5
but I would say the price is
um pretty minor it's like
0.03 dollars or something or a thousand
tokens per one of the models
so that was it for using the API uh
hopefully I've given you guys a much
better
intuition on how this works
so uh one last thing that we can do is
actually the finding our prompt through
error Labs so
as you can see all of this was just
asking it a question and what we
continue to sort of help with asking
better questions is asking the model
itself to make a better question so what
we can do is like
uh can you trace this question
to be more
so here
consists and to the point
and then you would just ask it like
what is python
or
that's pretty concise already maybe we
could do like
um
if I had three apples and my brothers
father Eric or
how many do
in total
and so we can just you know run that
thank you
yeah so it makes it a lot about concise
and you can use this as your prompt
instead of your other prompt and the
reason why this is helpful because is
because you can cut down the token size
and so you know open AI charges you less
we're using more concise plugs so you
can just say reduce this
and hit submit
yeah so this is just a match token so uh
over time if you keep calling some
prompt you can just optimize it through
charge GPD so
so that was it for prompting now let's
go into actually applying this into some
projects my first project will be
cloning the entire chart GPT UI and
assigning it a custom personality so
that we can interact with uh you know
custom characters let's unveil it users
we're gonna be using the chains that
package in order to make our chat GPT
column
so chain lit is basically this framework
that allows us to build user interfaces
really easy if you have had experience
with a package like streamlit you can
imagine chain that is like streamlit but
for a large language model applications
so comes with a bunch of different
features and unique Integrations and
ideally uh this is what our end goal is
going to be as shown by this video
so just skip through
yeah so
as you can see it's a pretty pretty
feature-itch user interface
and now let's get started building this
okay so now let's actually get started
with uh cloning this user interface
the first thing that we're going to want
to do is import our change that package
and the way we install it before we
import is we go to the terminal and
ignore everything that's happening here
all we need is uh just a python
environment and you will do this command
so bip install chain lid and we're doing
this in the terminal tab so once you do
that
it should install all your packages
and if you haven't already you'd want to
do pip install openai as well
and so this basically installs all the
packages from
external source that you can use to you
know work with chain bit and all these
features
okay so now let's start our first goal
will be the created user interface that
just outputs everything that the user
inputs
let's start by doing defining a tag so
so on message you would Define a
function
uh main this would be as asynchronous
don't worry about async because that
just means that it's going to wait for
the user to send the message
so it start executed immediately so
basically this function main takes in uh
the parameter of message which is
supposed to be this is going to be a
mapped to a string so this message is
going to be whatever the user inputs and
all we're going to do is we're going to
say await chain that scl CL dot uh
message and then we're going to send
this
and right now what it's going to do is
it's just gonna return an empty object
so what we have to do is we have to
actually uh specify what we want in the
contract so in the content here we can
uh yeah so in the content we can just
say message
addressing message because that's what
the user inputs
and I think yeah so this is about it
for our basic example what we can now do
to run this and actually see our user
interface is in your terminal again uh
you have to learn to get really familiar
with your terminal because it can be
really useful for the upcoming projects
so go to terminal and just run chain
later on and look at your bicon file's
name minus main.py here so I'm just
going to put main.py and then I'm just
gonna use the W flag so you should
really remember that
um you know you should remember that
you're not supposed to run a chain with
program with your run but run button so
I'll make this more clear uh after we
run this command
okay so as you can see it's running on
localhost Port it calls it
is just just just so that we have
complete Clarity we will be using the
screen button to drop something for code
but this executes
it in a server and chain that helps us
you know deal with the server and all of
the back end so all we have to do is
just run that commit and now if we just
put it in high uh you know
whatever uh whatever the user inputs the
chatbot will out
so for some of you running this for the
first time it might not actually look
like this you might have a bunch of
random text that's appearing there like
welcome to chain lit and the reason why
that's happening is because of the chain
the dot MD file so here's just a sneak
peek up where we're going to be covering
in the future but for now go to this
channel.md file as you can see mine is
empty but yours might be just full of a
bunch of text and all you have to do is
that none of the text here is imported
so you can just you know Ctrl a and
delete all of it or you can add
something like welcome to this interface
Begin by
sending uh wait that's it or something
like that so once you do this hit
command s which saves it as you can see
because of our W flag that we put here
uh the server actually watches for
changes so one as soon as we hit the
Ctrl save it says file modified change
the dot MD preloading app and it should
be reloaded yeah okay so it as you can
see it says welcome to this interface
Begin by sending a map subtract there's
a CFI and it goes away but as you can
see it just outputs everything that we
have a couple of more options that we
have in this user interface is
hiding you know chain of part and
expanding these messages but more
broadly you know you can double between
dark more in light mode I'm gonna stick
to dark mode for this tutorial
okay so now we pretty much have you know
the basis
and the user interface all we have to do
now is pass the message into
into the API
and we should and then you know just dot
send
the answer
right
so let's let's do that now and this is
going to be pretty easy because we've
already done this uh bunch of times in
the collab notebook what we're gonna do
is just you know wait for
okay so here all we're gonna do is maybe
just make something called response here
and in this response object we're just
going to put uh the chat completion and
dot create
and in this we're gonna put our model
our uh we're just gonna leave that empty
for now
and our messages
again
MD for now
and
maybe your temperature so why not come
for a shirt
equals something
so you you need to remember to put
commas after all of them except for the
last one
and commas between the messages as well
so the model can be anything you want
another gbd4
and the messages
is an array of dictionaries so in the
dictionaries you'll need to pass two
parameters you'll need a role and you'll
need the contact
and I'll explain what that is in just a
second
so again roll
or whatever that is and then the corn
bat
a temperature you can decide to build
you know whatever you want between zero
and one or two
and once we're done with this we gain a
tourism singer
yeah it should be fun Okay so
so since so in our role
uh key value pair we can just put this
as the assist step
and here we're just gonna put it as the
user
so as you can see here basically what
happens is that this is the assistant
message as you've seen in the chat GPT
playground and this is
saying that uh you you're like asking
the aggression basically so in the
content for the system message you can
put you are uh helpful
assistant
and in the in the user message we're
actually going to pass in our message
variable that's passed on by the user
and once we have this we instead of you
know content equals whatever the user
messages we're just gonna return the
response from childcpd
Okay so
now let's run this again same command in
terminal
okay so it's saying uh no idea keep
provided
let me provide will make the idea
and
so maybe
uh we can just we'll store it
started
and then we can just put this in so and
skip it
save that
hey then just say
just something I'm going to draw it here
and I'm not quite sure we're going to
drop
so let's try to debug this maybe
uh
okay so maybe what we can try doing is
just try this response into a string
and hit save
let's let's see if this works
okay perfect
so yeah um basically the mistake I made
was that this was just returning just an
object a Json object and the content on
the uh support strings
so as you can see in this object again
uh let me just you know redo that okay
so here
to my message hi it says content is
hello how can I assist you today and
obviously we don't want any of this
other stuff around it and as I've shown
you guys in the collab tutorial all
we're gonna do is just uh remove these
brackets and then we're gonna index our
way through to get our message so
we're gonna go to choices
and then inside choices we're gonna pick
the zero the element
and then the zero element we're gonna go
to the message
and then send message where it went to
go to content
okay
so
all of this is going to be wrap in an
app string so I'm just gonna
put this
like such and then you just remove this
and then you put this here
Okay cool so once we did once we do this
let's just put a cover here where say
I'm not 60 and then
Mom they're saved about
so now let's try running it again
oh yeah okay so
it works you can uh uh you know
tell me
a short one like
story
yep so as you can see we've successfully
cloned the chat GPD user interface and
we can also uh call our API through this
and modify any of our parameters here to
suit the content
now what we're going to do is something
interesting where we can sort of talk to
the model
um that is assigned a specific
personality so what what I mean by that
exactly is we're going to be able to
change the user message to something
that changes its personality so here you
can say like you are an assistant
that is obsessed with
power rabies Legolas
all right so once you do that you can
just hit Ctrl save it should modify a
bunch of times and
you know you can just start by sending a
message so Phi
and once we wait for a while it should
return us the output
so yeah it it follows the system message
and it really pays attention to it
because as you can see here you know
it's obsessed with legless
so this is how you can assign uh
personality to it and this is how uh if
you've ever gone to GitHub training
repositories there's a bunch of these uh
you know different
different uh repositories that all they
do is just you know change the
system message to make it behave a
certain way and that's exactly how
you're able to get this Behavior without
fine dma
so next let's address some limitations
of this approach so we have successfully
built uh working chat gbd clone but
there are a couple of limitations to
this regarding the user experience
so there's no streaming involved and
streaming is basically this live uh
token prediction of outputs that happens
instead of just processing the output
all at once and passing it directly
there's no generating the messages
um Mass uh you know button or message
that basically helps the user actually
identify it the backend process is
running
because otherwise you'll just have to
wait without any confirmation on whether
or not anything is actually happening on
the back end
and additionally after that there is no
back-end context
and by that I mean the user doesn't know
what kind of llm or what is actually
running in the background this third
feature is pretty optional but it's uh
very useful when it comes to debugging
when we go into more complex large
language model systems
so let's see how we ideally wanted to
look like this is from the official
chain that website as you can see there
is streaming here you know these tokens
are being spit out live there is this
background step that I talked about and
it reaches to rewind the video again uh
you can see that that stop task button
there allows us to actually see whether
or not this llm is actually generating
and we are able to stop the flow
so how do we get here
the answer to that is through Nang chain
so line chain is the most popular python
library that helps us deal with error
ramps it has some pretty Advanced
functionality uh you know excluding
whatever we just talked about here and
we're going to be using this extensively
in later parts of our course when we're
going to web browsing agents and using
our tools with agents so anyway let's
get into our land check implementation
now
great so now let's look into how to
actually integrate Lang chain so that we
get access to all of those user-friendly
features this is what we're going to be
working with now uh I'm just gonna you
know stop that app that we just ran for
running and we're gonna pip install
and this is very important U Lang chin
and what this EU flag does is it
basically installs the very latest
version of blank chip and the reason why
that's important is because line chain
is a library that gets updated pretty
much you know every week or so so
anything that works today might be
depreciated or discontinued next week
and in order to you know keep all your
dependencies in check we're going to be
having to you know update our land chain
so we I just defined a random string
here so
this template just gonna allow the llm
to think step by step as it does here
and the first feature I'm going to show
you from Land chain
is prompt template so if you guys have
ever worked with the python format
function this is pretty much the same
thing
what I mean by this is uh this is just
vanilla python so I'm just gonna do uh
template dot format and then inside this
question equals uh
you know whatever you want like what is
one two three four whatever so let's
just I'll happen on this
okay my bad um you're supposed to
print this up okay so let's just print
this up
yep so
what it does is it takes this template
variable and then it formats it to one
two three four but
how's that actually happening well these
curly braces indicate that this is an
object that needs to be formatted so
everything inside this curly braces is
going to be replaced by uh what is one
two three four and that's exactly what
prompt template does but it makes it a
lot easier and a lot more llm friendly
so we're gonna
get right ahead with the line chain and
change that implementation we're going
to just Define two tags here we're gonna
do CL dot on message as well
and once we do this we are going to
yeah so we are just going to
create a main chat so we're gonna just
Define our main function here and inside
this we're gonna do our prompt equals
something our llm chain equals something
and then CL dot user session dot set
all right
llm shin
tool as an M chain so
and chain
you can set that to
llm
shin
okay so now that we have that let's
actually uh go into
what we're doing here so what on chat
star does is as soon as this object of
you know the chain lit UI is deployed
here are the variables that we need to
initiate
so I'll just um
yeah I'll just create the prompt here so
prompt template is the object and set
this we're gonna put our template as
template
and it takes some random term I take
some template and with this it takes an
input variable so input variables
because you have something else so in
this case our template would equals
the template variable and our input
variable is the stuff inside the girly
bracket so that's this question
okay so that's it for our prompt and now
let's initialize what our llm shape so
what is an llm chain here and llm chain
for now you can think of it as something
that connects the prompt with our large
language model
so in this case let's just uh
foreign
a bunch of uh parameters so we're going
to do prompt equals something or else
the lamb equals something
and our streaming equals something and
our employables equals something so I'm
I'm gonna go through all what all of
these mean
and the reason why it's showing that is
because
it needs to be commas so our prompt is
basically just our prompt uh which is
the variable I Define here
uh and our slm which is going to be the
regular open AI model but there's a
different way to define it now instead
of you know going through the hassle of
doing a bunch of different uh you know
API calls all you need to do is just
open Ai and when we pass in our
temperature temperature here
and my bad streaming is supposed to be
uh parameter inside the alarm itself so
uh streaming you can just set to true
and this would you know stream yard and
temperature will set the one for that
after this verbose is basically uh our
hot process this will make more sense
when we cover the agents tutorial but
you can think of verbose for now as just
this extra additional text that goes
into and you know helps the llm with
resume so the thought process that leads
up to the answer and then we're going to
take this llm chain and then we're gonna
store it in a user session variable
called llm chain so that we can access
it on the on message call
so in our on message call where you know
this we've done this one already let's
define a mean another main function and
there are message B string whatever and
inside this we're gonna retrieve the
chain from our user session so llm chain
equals CL dot user session dot get so
this time we we did get instead of set
and in here we're just going to build
llm Shake
which is the variable that we passed in
here
okay so that basically just gets us this
variable across tags and after we've
done this
it's just pretty simple now uh all we do
is just
uh call it a desert result variable so
instead of calling our model itself
we'll now be calling our llm chain so
what we do is await llm underscore chain
dot asynchronous call and then inside
this we're gonna do our message and then
call back so don't worry about what this
callbacks thing is it just helps with uh
streaming
uh it helps its streaming because you
know it just calls back and establishes
a socket an action from what I
understand with it and then afterward we
do this all we do is just
return or output as we've always done so
CL Dot message
and then we're just gonna sell you that
and then here we're going to do result
address
um
text
so as you can see the
although this may not save a lot of you
know lines of code and might be slightly
more we have a much more organized
framework to think about things now
because once we adopt this land chain
framework uh you can you know sort of do
stuff that's a lot more complicated than
what we're doing within similar lines of
code so an example of this is what we're
going to be covering next uh you
obviously you're not expected to
understand if this right now but all of
this is very close to uh how many ever
we're doing here and this is infinity
more complex than what we're attempting
to do here
so once we're done with that let's
um go back and fetch our API key
okay
so once we're done with just putting our
API Keys uh we can actually
test this out and look at all of our new
features
so let's change the drawing
and then change that run and
I file name here's 19. integration
right yeah Dot py and then we're just
gonna put a watchdog there then
so just wait for that to run
okay great so now if we put high as you
can see we get everything that
was in the media that I showed you so hi
what is your question about you know a
thought process here is there's a
question about
this thought process stuff is going to
be more relevant once I look into other
Concepts but this is basically the same
thing you can just say uh what is your
name
how are you doing
so and it's actually streaming here and
then passes us the final output
bad yeah so everything that you did
previously with your API you can sort of
uh test out working with our system
message here uh you can desktop working
with different user messages different
parameters like dog B
Etc
and now let's get into something that's
slightly more interesting
we're gonna be able to
use this line chain framework to ask
chat GPD questions on our own PDF and
text documents that could be you know
any size like 2000 pages
so more on that now
so now let's talk a little bit about
battery databases and embeddings
here are some examples that you might
have heard of we're going to be using
chroma DB and some of the others for
this course
so what are vector databases what two
databases are basically this database or
storage for specifically embedding
information
Vector databases allow us to query and
utilize the this embedding information
as fast and efficiently as possible
so what's an embedding well and
embedding is just this multi-dimensional
space where all the similar objects are
grouped together so in this case
um in the Simmons all the symbols that
represent two are sort of grouped
together all the symbols that represent
four are grouped together and all the
symbols that represent nine are grouped
together
so why is this important well when you
have the ability to group some similar
objects based on a bunch of different
parameters together you can build
recommendation systems you can build
search engines
if this is also used in L Adams
themselves in generative Ai and for this
specific case we're going to be using it
for context window expansion
so if you remember from one of the
previous slides in the introduction I
said that fine tuning is not a very
recommended way of enhancing a model's
knowledge well this is where Vector
databases come in because while fine
tuning has its disadvantages because of
catastrophic for gaming Vector databases
just simply retrieve the relevant
context information for the language
model so it can use it what do I mean by
this well let's get into this let's get
a little more technical into this so say
I have this 2000 page PDF which I want
to use and I have a couple of questions
about it and I want to be able to ask
sharp CPT or any other Ram uh this
question
in general where if you'd want to do
this I guess the naive way would be to
just copy paste every single letter in
that
um in that book and just paste it into
the chat GPT terminal window but
obviously this won't work because you'd
be hit with a context limit because the
there's a max number of tokens that can
be inputted into chat GPT
and the way to get around this context
help it work with new information is
where Vector database is coming so
basically I'm just going to put this PDF
into a text splitter which will split it
into
text chunks of equal length so you can
imagine like just five words sentences
or a thousand word sentences and once
these chunks are made they put into
something called an embeddings generator
and these embeddings are then stored in
our Vector database
so now what's cool about this is we can
actually ask the question and the vector
database performs an action called
cosine similarity and what cosine
similarity is is it finds the nearest 10
or however how many are you want uh 10
relevant sentences Within These
embeddings so the 10 closes sentences
and then it just outputs them so that's
what the embeddings and the vector
database do and this Vector database
returns those 10 relevant sentences
and these 10 relevant sentences go into
a question answering model along with
our question so that it can be answered
and the reason why this is important is
because we went from a 2000 page book to
10 relevant sentences based on any query
and to me 10 sentences is obviously a
lot more manageable and useful in a
model than you know a 2000 page book
so why use Vector databases I have said
before like cosine similarity is the
only function that Vector B databases
actually perform along with storage so
why can't you just put all these
embeddings into something like an array
and do a cosine similarity function with
them it's certainly possible but the
reason why Vector databases are just so
popular and being used so much is
because they have clever algorithms that
help us retrieve all these relevant text
information at super fast speeds along
with a lot more efficient memory
efficient usage
additionally it's also very convenient
because we just we can just retrieve
those 10 relevant sentences through one
simple function call
so this is going to be the architecture
for project 2 as I've already mentioned
we're going to be able to we're going to
build this entire Pipeline and one very
important distinction I want to make
here is the difference between our
embedding generator and Q a model if you
remember from the number classification
example I told you that the task was
digit classification and it's able to
group those uh you know symbol similar
symbols together
this is very similar but here you're
doing that next
um you know that next token word
prediction problem
and this is there's an important
difference here because the embeddings
generator neural network
and the Q a model are very different
the embeddings generated neural network
for this case we're going to be using
something called Adda 2 because it's a
lot more efficient and it's sort of um
you know the standard for generating
embeddings whereas the Q a model is
going to be something like gpt3 and gpd4
um in in theory it is definitely
possible to generate embeddings through
gpt3 and gpt4 but add a uh tends to
perform better and is a lot cheaper
so now let's get into the code
so now let's get some more hands-on
experience with
how Vector databases work basically
what we're going to be using for this
tutorial is chroma DB which is an open
source Vector database that we can run
locally on our machine as pretty
scalable for production
so the way we get started is we just do
pip install chroma DB
and it should be installing everything
but
if you ever face any problems with
installation and I say this because I
have personally faced a problem of
editing out here when I try to install
this package for the first time the way
you fix that is running this command
that I've commented out here so if you
do that the you know the errors will
restart the clocks out
once we do that we can set our chroma
client equal to you know just our Chrome
idb so that we can start querying our
our question so here we can do
collection
and then inside this you do chroma
client dot create a collection and you
can think of a collection as basically
this place where we store our embedding
so this is the actual uh Vector database
so so my correction will be our Vector
database
this is supposed to be chroma
okay and now since we say that it's
supposed to be our Vector database
we can add information to this Vector
database in the form of three variables
so there is a documents variable there
is a metadata variable
and then there's an ID variable
so our collection object contains all
these three and let's go through them
one by one and understand them step by
step so document takes a list a metadata
sticks on this ID stakes and arrest
so document
is the actual list of our documents if
you remember from
the slide explanation that I gave you
all of our you know tokenized and split
text go into this document so with this
example I can just say my name is akshat
maybe and
another thing I could add is my name is
not akshat
and then
we can uh we can Okay so let's just do
that
and uh this is supposed to be documents
by the way my bad
and
after we've done this obviously this you
can you can put as many documents as one
and here they're gonna put our metadata
so
in this example it's not really going to
be important and I'll explain to you why
metadata is going to be very important
when we uh then we're able to
when we're able to build our question
answering system
so for now let's just put all of our
resources so it has to be one source per
document
my source
and you know what maybe let's just
change this to name is true and here
let's set it to name his fault so this
will not be this will not affect any
Vector database retrieval or competition
this just acts along with the steps
and they're each you know ID
um each each document has to have a
unique ID so id1 ID do
and once we're done with that we can uh
sort of look into what metadatas is so
in so let's just uh imagine that we
finished our uh you know PDF retrieval
problem which is that we have uh
successfully been able to use strategy
PD to answer questions on our PDF even
if you know this model achieves
state-of-the-art performance it's still
prone to a maybe a little bit of
hallucination
and there's obviously a risk of that
happening and sources help combat that
because even if the model hallucinates
it will be forced to uh sort of output
The Source from which it got its
information so even if it misinterpreted
the information the user can go to that
source and find out exactly what uh the
source is and sort of interpret it
themselves so that there is no
misinformation being spread
so that's it for collection and now we
can we can pass in a results object here
and inside this results variable we can
just query The Collection so
collection.query
and square your object ticks and do
things it takes in query uh texts
they're just going to put a singular
text in for now but you can pass
multiple questions in here and then end
results
so end result is the number of results
obviously and query text this is your
question so here this will be what is my
name
right so once we do that we can then uh
Delete all this and then just say print
results
okay so now let's run the code and see
what this has to say okay so it returns
us with this so what it's happening is
it takes this collection variable it
queries it so what that means is it
takes the what is my name uh string and
it performs a cosine similarity function
between what is my name and my name is
akshat
and it returns to me the distance
the metadata
the embeddings there's no embeddings for
now and in the documents so the
embeddings are not being stored at the
moment but we will be using Adda in the
next example to do this but for now
imagine that you know this is something
that was just learned so what what the
other thing we can do is you know make
this a number of results equals two and
we can compare which one is more similar
or closer to answering the question so
as you can see here my name is akshat
has a distance of 0.83 but my name is
not akshat has a system distance of 0.93
so since this distance is closer you
know the lower the distance the closer
it is to answering the question uh this
is going to be favored and in a top case
situation we're gonna be passing this
sentence here into our language model
over this one
so that was it for you know just the
fundamentals of vector databases now
let's apply this and whatever we've
learned so far in this course is
something more exciting we're going to
be able to build a PDF and text bot that
can answer any of our questions on a
given PDF or text file of any length
so now we have everything we need to get
started with building our first document
question answering system which is
Project number two
so for the sake of Simplicity
um we're just going to be using uh PDF
and text files as input to our project
but certainly everything that you learn
here is going to be easily generalizable
to you know any other text file that
contains text so
before we get started let's import the
necessary packages so there's this
package here and if you just skip to
this one tutorial insert without
watching the previous one you'd want to
install chroma DB
uh pip install chroma
comma DP
yeah
yeah sorry so control chroma DB
and once you do that you're going to
want to run this command here this is
very important
but only run it if you're facing any
errors with you know um
if you're facing any errors with coma DB
so anyway let's get started uh we just
imported our packages here and let's
look into what's happening so just a
quick recap on our architecture
we have here that uh you know this PDF
gets passed into a text better embedding
generator gets stored in the embeddings
query uh you know Vector database finds
the closest
um set of 10 sentences to this query
using cosine similarity then those 10
sentences along with the query are
wrapped into the Q a model and then q a
model like gbt for lgbt3 it just it then
passes the answer out as our output
so let's look at what's happening there
so our text splitter as I've said before
is
you know this
this element here
and we get to choose what the chunk size
is which is the size of the sentence
chunk so here I just put a thousand
characters but you can uh you know you
can experiment with different types and
then we Define our embedding Sayer here
so open AI embeddings as a default uh
uses the adder
adder to model and that generally
provides the best performance along with
you know the cheapest cost outbreak so
after that this is just a welcome
message is this user interface and here
we've defined two functions so uh here
we've defined a process file function as
well as a doc search function so what
I'm going to do is I'm just going to
zoom out momentarily to just you know
give us a bird's eye view of what's
happening okay so
the process file is basically uh this
you know this feature that La uh this
feature that chain that offers where you
can just input a bug so you can assume
that most of this is this boilerplate
till here
but after this uh Point here is where we
actually call the text figure so
everything this function is doing is
just taking the you know taking the
embeddings here uh doing the text
picture and applying it on our PDF file
and then once we have all the chunks you
can then label them as sources so more
on this later let's move on to our doc
search so doc search is obviously where
we you know retrieve our data from our
embeddings so once we've sort of split
these documents into the smaller chunks
we can then process our file here and
you know set it in our user session so
don't worry about this too much this
just make sure that I our docs are
available to both the mod around the
client
and the doc search uh you should be
pretty familiar with this if you uh gone
over the previous segment so all we're
doing is we're just uh using the
literary we're defining like retrievers
here and the chroma DB takes all these
embeddings uh along with you know the
model of embeddings and it just Returns
the relevant query so that's what this
this does
okay so now
is the actual you know chain that user
interface interactions part and I've
divided this whole uh action space here
into two functions so let's just zoom in
and
see what each one uh is about so
one second
so
here we're defining an on chat start tag
and basically what this does is you just
um pass in a bunch of different you know
bottle bits text zero you can just put
whatever you want so uh welcome
do this space you can eat
use this to check with your idiots okay
and so once we send this message we can
move on to yes all the more important
lines here so here as you can see it
says while files equals none you'll want
to ask for a file and here's where you
can change uh what kind of file you're
actually inputting so after this
tutorial I would recommend you guys to
do some research and then experiment
with using CSV files so here we're just
accepting text and media with the max
size of this much but you can obviously
ask for more and you know just just send
that out as a message
so basically once this is done we can uh
once the user has inputted a pile we
then say processing and then the name of
the file and then we basically just call
these two functions here and return all
that output still here so you're just
doing
um
my bad okay so here so you're just doing
you know you're just setting our we're
getting a retrieval chain ready and
setting it here so more on the retrieval
chain now this is a new kind of chain uh
that we've learned language so the
before we just did a basic
you know other than chain but here we're
doing the retrieval q a with sources
chain so as I've mentioned before chains
basically unite The Prompt and you know
the model together but now we can add a
sort of other layer of abstraction to
this definition where
chains basically combine prompts llms
and other functions to this
together so in this case it combines a
retriever which is
which are uh you know these embeddings
here so this is a retriever which is our
Vector database
our model is the chat GPD you know this
model and our retriever is you know this
doc search as a retriever function
so once we're done with that we can then
you know just pass in pass this out and
set this chain save this chain into our
user session so that our backend can
actually access this
so now this is what the back end looks
like
let's let's go through this step by step
because we've pretty much done all the
work already you know we've established
everything here and here is the place
where we're actually going to call all
our functions so here as you can see
this is an on message function so
whenever a message happens uh you would
get fetch this chain this is retrievable
chain and then you would
you would basically just
uh you know just strip your API and make
the answer presentable and then just you
know give it to the user but all this we
could we could just stop it here you
know we could just stop it here but a
problem with large language models
currently is that sometimes very rarely
they do hallucinate and make up
information when the context sent this
sliding around
and the way we can get around this is to
provide citations to the user about
what's actually happening so even if the
large language model collusionics if the
user is interested in doing further
research which you know he should be for
the sake of this example he can just
click on the sources button and then he
can read what's actually you know the
the actual retriever output so uh that
that's what this section fear does
whereas sources you know we just
classify our services here and it
outputs our solution so all of this will
make more sense once I uh
done
oh bye I don't think I don't remember
defining any open the eyed key here so
might ask Nate to do that
yep open API key let's just go ahead and
get an open API Okay so
openai.com
login
and once you're in the login page you
can just hit API and then
view API keys so I've created one
already but I'm just going to create a
new one which I will definitely
disable as soon as this video ends so
create secret View and they'll just use
this
fail
on
or did I
I mean
okay this should work let's let's try
doing this again
okay I think I know what's happening
here so import OS
so generally when you're using packages
I think it expects you to you know give
it in this one rather than what I Define
so just so that it's easier for it back
just to identify what the keys so let's
for the last time hopefully let's try
this again
yeah okay so it works we'll
and this opens up here so welcome to the
space you can use it to chat with your
PDFs great so
this is exactly what
we've intended it wanted to do so now
what we can do is we can just drop in a
PDF file
so what I did here was I just passed in
you know this Sapient huge history of
humankinds just a short extra profit a
PDF but since uh this process is running
locally you're pretty much unbounded by
how much you data that you can input
into this model so you'll see that it's
processing here and
what processing basically means is it's
putting these text things into chunks is
generating embeddings and passing the
embeddings into the vector database so
that we can you know perform all these
steps here
so let's just wait for that to happen
one node is that at the time of
recording this
um I don't think chain that supports the
drag and drop feature into files
although it does claim to do that so
your best bet is to just hit the browse
button and then choose the file in the
you know window that displays so anyway
uh sapiens it's processed so we can
you know ask it some questions so a
question from this book would probably
be like what is the in the Indian Theory
and so as you can see here
it shows me the retrieval q a chain
with sources chain
and you know it should be shorter it
sort of shows me its hot process here
which is exactly what this is so let's
just go deeper into this Shin so the
retrieval with sources come by is a
combination of the stuff documents chain
and the llms chain so that they can
return our sources so let's just look
into the actual output here and you know
it so it answers the question obviously
but what's more important here and
what's more interesting is are the sword
lists so I can say you know Source 42
it's not that great at formatting
because you know the PDF is just a
non-structured text and also a
tokenization and chunking could sort of
affect the alignment but this is pretty
easily you know fixed you can just
remove Extra Spaces
so
again I recommend you to you know play
with this and sort of test out what you
can do to improve this further
or I would you know initially
like you guys work on is maybe removing
these spaces between
uh between these text spaces here and
just keep asking it questions and see
how it responds with uncertainty as well
so if I ask it something like Port is
CPM till it is uh safety I'm
the spawn
in a bowl with citations
so I have no idea what this answer is
kind of output
but yeah
so yeah
it you know Jordan answers the question
but as you can see it doesn't really
respond in a pawn which is kind of a
litigation and you can sort of
experiment with how well you know you
can make these and how flexible you can
make these uh a quick fix to this would
be you using an agent that first you
know retrieves these sources and this
answer and then you would pass this back
into the llm so that it can make it a
bomb so you could you know experiment
with that although we are going to be
covering agent structure
so that's all for our q a with documents
so now we're getting into some of the
more advanced things that we can do
and we're going to be looking
specifically into the web browsing and
agent capabilities of llms
so why would you want an uh an agent to
sort of browse the web well the reason
is because there is a knowledge cut off
uh in with the training data and you
can't train a model on an infinite
amount of data because that would be
very expensive and time consuming
instead you you'd want to train a
reasoning engine rather than a database
and you'd want to train something that
can just have access to all these
resources and synthesize it themselves
rather than having some internal
knowledge base that uh that you know
can't be changed
additionally some of the information
that you might train an alarm on might
be biased and might be susceptible to
you know changes in the future which it
hasn't accounted for yet and browsing
the web helps us reduce this because it
always has access to the latest
information
so now we're gonna go into agents which
allows uh these LMS to perform Chain of
Thought reasoning well here's an example
of what I mean this is from the auto GPT
GitHub repository
welcome to this brief demonstration of
Auto gpnc
today we'll be showcasing the ai's
learning ability by asking it to
research information about itself
let's begin the program's first step is
to use Google to find relevant websites
to what it's researching
foreign
the GitHub repository for auto gbt it's
opened up for analysis
after scanning the website's contents it
is summarized to them and will now place
them in the auto gpt.txt file we have
opened
as we can see auto GPC can teach itself
about different topics using the
internet allowing it to have a better
understanding of the current world than
chat should be deep
so
order GPD is what we call an agent and
the way it works is this really cool way
where it prompts itself so the user just
gives it a prompt and it can formulate a
plan and then input that plan back into
itself and then output an action
input that action back into itself and
it can arrange all these chains of
thoughts into a pretty sophisticated
workflows that you can use to answer
questions and now read more recently you
can actually perform you know actions in
the real world
so the first problem that we're gonna
try to solve in this basic course is
what is our lecture we're gonna be we're
gonna want to ask the agent this
question and it should be able to use
its tools to find the answer on the
internet reason why it doesn't know the
answer to what is rlhf is because
reinforcement learning from Human
feedback or our lecture is a New Concept
that has only been discovered or
invented in 2022 to 2023 so chart GPT
having its knowledge cut off in 2021
would not be aware of this whatsoever so
we're trying to empower it to sort of
research and learn about these things so
that can answer us
so how are we gonna do this we're gonna
use Lang chains archive API
or integration to do this so archive is
an is a platform that allows us to have
access to over 2 million scholarly
articles in various builds from physics
to economics to computer science and it
pretty much details all the latest
research and information that's
available to us
here is what the website looks like just
in case it might be a little familiar
and now that's
go to the solution so we need a model
that can know its resources and utilize
its resources and furthermore it needs
to be able to plan how to use these
resources sequentially step by step
prompt by prompt and
when I say prompt by prompt I mean it
can it should be able to prompt itself
to finish the task without the need of
explicit programming as well as not
being stuck stuck in loops
so thankfully all of this is going to be
covered or sort of has been taken care
of by line chain already but uh as it
has conveniently implemented for us a
research paper called the react
framework that we can just use
um to make any other laminated
so here's what um
something like an agent uh here's one
algorithm that you could use
or you can just pause this video and
look at this in more detail but now
let's just start with a simple example
and dive into the code
so now we're ready to actually Implement
project number three which is going to
be GPT researcher
so gbt researcher basically answers our
questions on pretty much the latest
fields of Science and can provide us
with citations if we ask it to
so
here's what we're going to be using if
you haven't uh ever heard of archive
before it's basically this website where
there's like a bunch of scholarly
articles that everything from you know
physics to math to economics
and it has pretty much all the latest
research
so let's get started here's the archive
Plugin or integration in chat GPD and
light chain and I've made a notebook
I I made a notebook in your GitHub
repository so that you can use it so
backwards skipping ahead here let's just
yeah here
okay
so here is internet browsing let's zoom
in a little bit so that we can see the
code better
okay
so we're just gonna import our basic
functions here and we're gonna
just Define our
open AI API key so let's try to find it
if I put it somewhere here
and we're gonna put this back into our
online
okay so once we've defined the API key
we can just look through some of the
basic things this should look super
familiar to you you know we've done this
a bunch of times already uh
this llm definition
and after that we have this special
parameter here called tools so basically
the tools you know parameter allows us
to store tools that the llm and the
agent can access based on its needs so
one thing that you can do maybe after
learning the other tools in this course
is you know just separate them with
commas and pass in some of the other
tools like wrap it
that's not exactly how you define it but
you can uh you can sort of integrate
that into this toolbox so once we Define
the Dual uh we Define a new type of
chain which is our agent chain
so as I've said before a chain basically
unites our prompts with our large
language models and our algorithms so in
this case the algorithm that we're using
is zero short react description
so this is the algorithm that allows the
llm think and you know prompt itself to
reach the right conclusions so we're
gonna set the max iterations to 5 so
that it doesn't you know get stuck in a
loop and it doesn't
um
it we you know it won't be built too
much for uh your API usage
so we're gonna be just passing our tools
here with our llm and then Max
iterations we'll post we'll get to that
and handling this you should set this to
true as well so after that all we do is
just agent chain dot run with whatever
question we have and let's observe uh
the output so
let's let's share it on this
so while that's running let's just look
at like sort of the uh to the many steps
that it takes so
this algorithm is called zero Shard
react description so all we're doing is
just asking it first word uh is you know
are the Chip And if it doesn't already
know that then it would identify an
action to perform and so the action to
perform here is archive which is our API
that searches the research paper domain
and then you would input the word r a
ledger into our archive API so that it
returns a bunch of you know research
papers that are search results obviously
this is not really presentable I I
shouldn't have to you know look through
all of this research to get my answer
so what it does is you know it observes
this output under observation and then
it has a thought here so our leadership
stands for reinforcement learning so it
takes in all of this research that it's
just found and then you know it
it just finds uh itself an answer to
this
so that's what
that that's how we're able to solve this
knowledge Gap problem that we have
an additional thing that you can do here
is yeah you can just ask it anything you
want so what is a black hole for example
and it will give you the answer so let's
just observe what the algorithm is doing
first so it's it identifies that it
searches it should search for a
scientific definition for that it
identifies the correct action this will
make more sense when you give it more
actions so that it actually has to
decide between what actions to choose so
it inputs the word black hole into the
action
and you know all this bead text here is
whatever is written by archive so it
looks at all this return text and then
it thinks meaning that it it you know it
um it takes in all this input and then
it just gives us an output based on what
it thinks so our final answer is a black
hole is the reason region of space-time
exhibiting gravitational acceleration so
strong that nothing no particles or even
you know the electromagnetic radiation
can escape from them
an interesting thing you can do here is
you can query sort of the other types of
data that come along with this research
paper so you can see like with titles
you know what were the authors in this
paper and was it when was it published
so that's all for the archive tool let's
move on to the other tool that I'm gonna
show
but before that let's look into
uh chain lit integration to just show
you how easy it is to incorporate agents
into you know a presentable UI so this
is a chain that integration all this
just boilerplate you know and all this
code here we've already we ran that in
the previous python notebook so you can
just copy paste it here the other thing
you need to remember is to store this in
an agent variable and then let's see if
this in the agent variable and the
answer should be agent.org everything
else is just boiler but it could uh and
yeah this allows you to spin the final
answer as well that's pretty cool
so let's now run our
agent
with
uh with chain with so again go to your
terminal and then just type in chained
run Internet
and browsing
okay
I apologize for the overly long file
names but just so then item number which
one contains what I should open up this
and okay so yeah as usual same error uh
let's just
copy paste our open API key back into
this book here
and this time let's make it a lot more
convenient
by adding that widget slide so
it should open it up again and now it
should be working yeah
so again whatever we uh just created
through the asian.run we can do the same
thing so what is iron HF
and you know I'm not familiar so it's
just using archive and then it says
title whatever the research that it
found and then
you know I now know the final answer so
this is the final answer
again what is uh black hole
yeah so you know it answers the question
for me and we can look at all the hot
process so one final note before we move
on to another tool is this parameter
here which is where both and basically
when you set it to false all it does is
it removes all this thought process here
and it just gives you the answer
and it's useful in a production setting
but I think it's kind of fun to just
look at vertex thinking and how it's
able to come to those conclusions so
that you know you can verify whether or
not choosing be like
so another tool that we're gonna use is
human as a Duo this is really cool
because
say your agent serve goes on the wrong
track
what you would want to do is you want to
validate it and sort of tell it what
it's doing wrong so that it can fix that
thought process and then move in the
right direction instead of having to
just run once and then you changing the
parameters you can just talk to it and
sort of make it work
and this is what the human has a tool uh
this is what the human has a dual
package solves so this is just a simple
you know scenario here uh you can look
through the code but obviously the only
difference here is that in the tools
array I've just put humans and other
than that too and I've just defined this
method I'm here so that I can do the
math so let's just run the human as a
tool.pi
and I'll tell you exactly learning again
I hope a night it'll open the attitude
I'll remember to add it to the other
ones
so
open aiti key and let's try running this
again
Okay cool so it's working
uh so it says I to figure out what the
math problem is and solve it and the
reason why is because I wrote the
question is what is my math problem and
basically what all I can do is I can
just say
if I have three apples and we will
how many more B filter
how Danny
this is a very basic example but
obviously uh it observes this and then
it uses the llm map calculator too and
it shows me that the answer is five now
the answer is two
so the reason why this is cool is
because you can use this tool as I've
mentioned before in between its thought
processes so if it uh thinks of a wrong
solution you can instantly give it
feedback and that's where you can sort
of just add this human to to your Cobra
cluster tools here
another tool that we can check out is
our adapter tool
so this is the python droplet tool and
I'm I think you're sort of noticing a
trend here where
you don't really need a lot of code in
order to deploy all these very complex
uh agents because blackshin has got this
covered for us already but if you want
more customization with your tools we're
gonna jump into that a little
in a little bit so let's just start
running this now and I'll explain what
this does
you can think of it as an alternative to
collab notebook
so basically what it does is it writes
python code and the limitation with chat
GPT is that it can't run its own port
right because it's not a computer so it
takes that code it puts it into Rebel
and it retrieves the output of that code
back to us so that you know it codes for
us
so here my question was what is the 10th
Fibonacci number and
here's you know a list of Fibonacci
numbers
um you know it identifies to the action
Spike on Rebel and the actual input is
the alphabenacci so this is the code
that goes into their apple and the
observation
is as such so the thought is that you
know it just prints out Fibonacci
Okay so
that was the python replied to obviously
all you have to do is just combine this
with uh every tool that I've mentioned
before in order to make it work so
another cool tool that we can explore is
the YouTube search tool
so YouTube search tool it obviously you
know it does what it says it does it's
just YouTube and in order to make this
work you actually need to install the
YouTube search package so let's just
install that
and the cool thing about YouTube search
too is that you can uh sorry give it
this framework here so this is another
way that you define a tool where we
Define an array of tool objects a tool
object is basically this uh you know
object that takes in three parameters so
in this case it takes a name takes a
function and it takes a description the
name can be anything I don't think it
matters that much the function is what
um what the activity that the language
model actually does when it's called
and the description is super important
because it tells it when to actually use
it so in this case when you're asking
for YouTube video links
you'll want to call this Duo so that's
why our description is you need to give
it links to YouTube videos and we wanted
to put https and all this stuff in front
of every link to complete them because
it only gives us you know the URL
address like whatever it would be it
doesn't give us the YouTube like so it's
not more convenient to click on the
links when you have that so again
initialize the agent with all the tools
of this stuff and I'm just gonna ask it
a simple question here which is what's a
Joe Rogan video on an interesting topic
so let's let's just try to run this have
I put my opening I can no then second
okay so we have our opening API key and
let's just share it to another list now
so as I mentioned before you know this
it just Returns the root value in our
observation so it just returns to slash
watch and what I asked it to do here is
to put https youtube.com in front of
every link so that it's actually
clickable so our final answer is this so
let's just click on it and see what it
gives us
experience I guess I'm talking about it
I must
so yeah it works it returns to us the
YouTube link and I've shown you how to
do this already but all you have to do
to integrate this into chain lit is just
copy paste all of this and replace this
this stuff here with uh you know all
this archive stuff that's all you have
to do it's super simple
let's go into more of the integration so
I can show you what you can do to
what you can do to research and explore
more tools there is the
there's the zapier land natural language
actions API tool that I recommend you
guys to explore on your own
I'm not going to be doing this one
because it's not the safest to show my
API keys
for so zapier is basically the service
that gives you over 5 000 different
Integrations I'll be covering the
national language actions API in a
future video but you know you can sort
of combine this with maybe a research uh
you know the archive research retrieval
by making a bot that every you know
single week it just Returns the latest
research on a specific topic and it can
like tweet it out put it as part of your
email newsletter zapier has all those
Integrations handle
the last tool we're gonna end on is
going to be the shelter
and once we're done with the shell tool
I'll just show you guys how to make your
own custom tools
so let's go to
the shop tool code is in the CLI GPD
dot Pi file and this is sort of
interesting because you're doing a
little bit of configuration here so
you're taking the shell tools
description
you're adding its arguments and you're
pasting these arguments with these so
that it's easier for the model to
execute the
local commands so what the shell tool
does is basically what we're doing in
this terminal except chat gbd can
actually run commands in our terminal
you know create text files and all of
that so
here's a basic example obviously you
know we'll just initializing the agent
or adding all of them it should be a lot
more familiar when I just
do that out there so once we do that uh
if we can just run the agent and my
question to the agent is create a text
file called empty and insert it add code
that trains a basic CNN for for ebooks
so
as you can see there's no there is an
empty.txt file from uh previous
test run of this so I'll just delete
that and
let's run the code again so see that GPD
on that
um
so let's let's do that
and maybe buttercups here
so okay this one would because it's
before 8 or so I'll just put this okay
so let's let's run this again
okay so let's enter in the execute to
chin and this is interesting because uh
we can
actually look at what exact commands
that it's passing through so that this
is sort of a step-by-step step
sequential reasoning problem where first
it it uses one two which is the terminal
2 and and this is the commander passes
in so touch D dot dxt
and then once the text file has been
created it
uh puts all of this text into empty.txt
and then you know it's thought step
and then it just opens until here is all
the code we're going for running that so
let's just check yeah this is actually
worked so empty.dxt is here and yeah so
it does have all the code that's
required
I'm just gonna end uh this tool section
by showing you guys how easy it is to
yeah again put all of these agent tools
inside shame with
so everything I'm doing here is just you
know all this stuff is boilerplate and
all I'm doing is just copy pasting what
I'd put in CLI gbd all this code here
and I'm just putting that in here and
then I put the agent dot running here
and store it in this variable so that's
that's let's just uh for once and Define
a API key
and then run it in chain so
chain that turn on
on so I've named this file called the
nation output
dot pi
and go for the Adobe effect
so but yeah we can basically do
everything that we did uh previously in
the previous python notebook but just
Enchanted so we can say what is are not
bought as well uh to know installed
I will
install numpy
package
in my environment
so as you can see it's okay through and
see what it can do so it knows that the
action is installed numpy so it just
does that and I wanted to show this to
you guys in specific
because this creates a really cool use
case where you can
um you can sort of automate the process
of learning how to record and uh
speeding up this process by using this
so say a beginner doesn't really know
how to you know install packages or
configure their environment you can just
use this terminal tool and launch it as
an application that helps them build
that I think um
when it comes out GitHub co-pilot will
be uh or should be using this tool to
make sure that it's very easy to manage
dependencies and just make the llm
handle all the point first word so that
you can focus on actually coding
so that's it for the CLI tool now let's
look into
word is pretty exciting which is our
custom tools
so I'm just going to give you guys a
super basic example of a custom tool but
know that you know it's pretty much
Limitless what you can do with this so
let's just uh stop running this code
and let's look into custom tools
so one important thing here is
you want to enable Lang chain tracing to
true so that you can actually Trace
through your function so that it knows
uh what to execute
so in this case again uh same Imports
same llm initialization
and this is where you get customization
so now in your tools array you can
actually Define your own custom tool
so in this case in the Dual object you
can pass in a name a function and a
description
our name can be anything you want and
our function is the parsing multiplier
so this is just a simple function that
multiplies two things together
not supposed to multiply yeah so it
multiplies two things together so and a
and b so when you pass in the input
three times four
a general calculator would not be able
to answer this because a it's a natural
language and B it requires like a little
bit of intelligence because uh you know
this is a number and this is a series of
strings so
this is our multiplier function and then
parsing multiplier basically takes in
these two
takes in a string uh that the llm inputs
into the parsing multiplier and just
splits it based on the comma and just
extracts A and B so that it can multiply
so an example of this is basically the
llm uh I'll just explain what that or
what I just said means so the llm would
look at these functions and then it
would out it would you know act as an
input in the function it would probably
do like three comma four as its input to
the function so this C comma 4 as a
string
so this is a string three comma four
gets passed into our parsing multiplier
where it's split into a and b so 3 goes
to a and 4 goes to p and then you would
return
the multiplier of A and B so since so
you would just convert them into
integers so you just return three times
four
so this is just one Custom Tool that you
can do obviously you can do a lot more
complex things you can call apis on the
back end you know you can hook it to
email you can do a bunch of stuff with
this so let's just run this llm chain
now
and see what it shows us custom tools
fail to the lower default bucket so it
works
I'm not quite sure why uh this would air
out but it it does show us uh the actual
uh agent chain so here it says I need to
multiply two numbers together because
that's what it's doing and the action is
multiplier and and input is three comma
four so the observation would be 12
because your action input 3 comma four
gets passed into our parsing multiplier
which is our function here parsing
multiplier splits it into a and b
Returns the multiplied output and so the
observation is 12 because the output of
our function is 12 and then it just says
you know I know the final answer
final answer is 3 times 4 x 12. so you
can change this function to maybe
dividing
obviously it's not the most creative
change
but you know when you can Define your
own functions and allow this allow them
to do things the possibilities are
pretty much Limitless
uh interesting thing I just saw here is
that I did Define this as division but
you know it's smarter than that because
I think it focuses more on the goal than
the actual means to get to the goal so
it
um you know even though the observation
is 0.75 it prioritizes its own like
common sense and knowledge maybe through
our Ledger techniques uh to make sure
that the silencer is not dry so it's 12.
so I'm just gonna leave you guys with
this this was the end of custom tools
and the last segment of this course
I'll just leave you guys with maybe one
thing to think about which is
the how the agents actually work right
now
is to zero shot react description so you
can think of this as basically a pretty
elaborate prompt combined with the
recursive algorithm so what I would
leave you to is instead of instructing
these values uh do you think they'd be a
way to sort of fine tune the llm based
on the output of multiple agents because
uh fine tuning is meant for Behavior
changes so could you just reinforce that
logical thinking Behavior inside an llm
itself so I won't have depend on outside
react Frameworks in order to work
if you've made it this far then
congratulations because you just
finished the course here's a list of
everything that we covered so far
this course has been brought to you by
loop.ai which is software that allows
you to create no code AI flows
in 10 minutes you'll be able to perform
all the actions that I've covered in
this course so far add a lot more with
no code
as well as in within 10 minutes or less
you can deploy and embed a custom AI
flow on any website and deploy an embed
a custom chat bot on any website from
Twitter to Instagram to your own
personal website to Shopify
I appreciate you guys taking the time to
learn from this course if you're excited
about the product head on to loop.ai and
sign up for Early Access subscribe to
our YouTube channel for highlights of
the course uploads per section
announcements and updates on the product
the YouTube channel is also going to be
the place where we're going to post any
of our future courses
follow us on Twitter to be the first to
be notified about all of our future
events and courses
and if you have any doubts queries
concerns regarding any part of this
course join the Discord for assistance
where me and my team are going to be
working every day to resolve these
doubts and conflicts
once again I appreciate you guys taking
the time to take this course thank you